Guarda cosa ti aspetta Qua sotto abbiamo
fatto una montagna tipo quanta roba c'è
in questo casino Adesso siamo stati
lanciati
qualcuno eh precisamente Siamo sul dente
di qualcuno Eh guarda questo personaggio
era solo molari Cioè guarda guarda
il 32 Ma possiamo saltare sulla sulla
lingua Oh pericoloso Non lo so potrebbe
deglutirti emotivamente magari saltiamo
qui ma senza prendere la saliva Wow
guardate questa è la lingua quella è ehm
ugola nuvola
non so come è possibile che siamo stati
mangiati ma lo scopriremo presto perché
in queste Escape Room dobbiamo scappare
da un corpo intero quindi non ci saranno
più eh il pavimento della lava o
sotterranei o fogne ma ci sarà
semplicemente tutto il corpo di questa
persona dobbiamo attraversarlo se c'è
tutto il corpo e tutto il corpo tutto
quanto dobbiamo con la pasta Marrone lì
con me dovrai passare lì Mi dispiace per
te ah ah ah ah Ma voi lasciate un bel mi
piace sotto questo video ragazzi Provate
a lasciare un mi piace entro 5 secondi
prima che io finisco di cadere nella
goccia Oh tre due tre due uno tre fa
scaduto
Ronaldo ancora Ronaldo se siete riusciti
a lasciare mi piace mi piaceva secondi e
con Vitale lì per terra eh perché perché
qua tutto là di nuovo eh rotola di nuovo
no Mi ha riportato sulla lingua era un
teletrasporto ho paura Uffa ora ti
raggiungo subito
Non vedo l'ora di vedere come hanno
realizzato tutto il corpo umano qua
dentro
il corpo umano
noi nel corpo umano abbiamo queste cose
Verdi tipo un po' ha fatto scale No e
non abbiamo neanche delle pizzette
Aspetta aspetta io potrei anche averla
delle
pizzette ma è stranissimo
un Parkour
Oh guarda qua Ci sono tipo
ha mangiato delle Mine No sempre Non ti
preoccupare
in mezzo ai piedi
ma aspetta un momento perché se io vado
lì poi mi riporta indietro è una
trappola Dove dove stai andando Scusa
non ho capito
c'è qualcosa che non quadra o meglio se
qualcuno
perché mi riporta
Ma basta Adesso ti faccio vedere io Sì
sì ciao il cioccolato il cioccolato
Guarda guarda venite da dove sei Sono
qui sul cioccolato veloce al cioccolato
quello non credo E che cos'è e forse
qualche parte del corpo tipo dei pezzi
di stomaco
Ma sì sono dei cioccolatini questi
naturalmente ho passato questa parte
Salviamo
bella non sono proprio cioccolatini
quelli guarda qui ci sono delle
ciambelle giganti vedi vedi
estrarre così arriverò devo stare
attento
sfracellamento ti sei sfracellata tu no
non sei ancora caduto perché il cibo mi
emoziona Quindi allora sono tornato
indietro Ho sbagliato lo sapevo il cibo
ti aspetto Sono qui dai io sono ancora
le ciambelle vai pure avanti vai pure
Allora mi mangio tutte queste mele
morsicate sono scivolato sulla pelle
ma nello stesso punto ma mi devo devo
fare tutto da capo adesso perché no
Sicuramente ti sei girato dalla parte
sbagliata Eh praticamente devo rifare
tutta quella parte qui i cioccolatini
che non sappiamo se sono cioccolatini ma
devo dire che non hai salvato Allora
ero distratto da questo cibo Sembra
facile Questo Parkour Ma non è per
niente facile Parkour ma Uffa Basta non
voglio cadere negli acidi dello stomaco
là sotto quelli verdi ci avevo pensato
sono gli acidi dello stomaco quindi mi
digerisce Eh sì ma quindi se siamo già
nello stomaco con me le
non ci credo Sono scivolato di nuovo
sulla mela
no siamo partiti estrarre
mela è molto più difficile di quello che
pensassi queste Escape Room del corpo
umano soprattutto le mele sono molto
difficili anche se possiamo vedere tutto
quello che ha mangiato mele cioccolatini
le carote intere
Quand'è che avevano una bocca molto
grande Quindi basta Non vi voglio più
entrare ho una domanda sono ancora viva
Che cosa sono queste cose bianche su cui
stiamo camminando cioè su cui sto
camminando No
ho scoperto un trucco che si può
camminare sì Se cadi giù eh senza
toccare Gli acidi dello stomaco Che
cos'è poi arrampicarti nella parete del
corpo e riesce a sopravvivere le carote
le carote sembrava una di quelle Escape
Room facili invece ma non ci credo
perché cado sempre proprio a quel punto
non solo l'ultima carota perché qua
bisogna prendere bene le misure ci
vogliono un po' di abilità di parkour
piano piano piano
devo saltare nell'altra carota che c'è
Sono scivolato
No non ce l'hai fatta e ancora le carote
mai Insomma basta vai avanti Appunto ma
mi piacerebbe andare avanti ma non so
come fare No sono stata uccisa dai
batteri
Ascolta ma è possibile è possibile
prendere la rincorsa su tutta la carota
per per cioè come si fa a prenderla
tutta questa rincorsa per saltare qui
l'Italia rimarrà per sempre lì bloccata
le carote e io forse rimarrò sempre
sbloccata qui a questi batteri no
allora piano
Guarda questo giocatrice abbia scritto
in inglese ti faccio vedere io come fare
e come far saltare velocissimamente Il
problema è che se io mi metto a saltare
velocissimamente non ci riesco più forse
ci sta riprendendo seguendo il suo
consiglio allora mi sono salvato Sono
qui sulle pareti dello stomaco
Scarlett Grazie Scarlett E tu dove sei
Beh che ci fai là sotto Eh sono riuscito
a salvarmi ma non so più dove andare eh
puoi prendere
non lo so perché io sto prendendo la
strada giusta vediamo vediamo dov'è
Anita Eccola la vita è lì Oh però Che
figo sono riuscito ad andare sopra in
avanti invece questa giocatrice ha detto
voglio che facciamo l'escape Room
assieme che carina ha fatto una nuova
amicizia
sì
potresti aiutare da dirmi quale partita
l'hai preso la scorciatoia il barato non
ti meriti nessun aiuto Ciao io vado a
prendere il badge No vabbè non ci credo
che sei già al badge Però io continuo ad
andare avanti e in che parte sei del
corpo Okay sono in una parte dove ci
sono degli atomi
Io invece qua
cosa Uh uh uh uh
cioccolato Sì sì sì infatti Tra l'altro
i biscotti al cioccolato adesso Oh no i
laser Adesso torno indietro vado a
prendere quei biscotti Ma devi rifare
tutta l'escape Room
sì Dov'è finita la mia amica che mi
stava seguendo ancora lì e biscotti e
invece non riesco andare avanti con i
laser Li odio tieni laser No aspetta c'è
qualcosa che è stranissimo Qui abbiamo
dei vermi più avanti
sembrano schifosissimi non li ho visti
da lontano ve l'ho detto eh Com'è
possibile che ci sono dei vermi qua in
questo cobra sono forse il verme
solitario e potrebbe essere proprio
quello il che vuol dire che siamo vicini
a quella zona lì forse no non credo che
sei già riuscito a quasi uscire e vabbè
io sono saltato Oh ok ok ok Allora
allora
questo richiede molta pazienza A chi lo
dici vedessi questi laser Quanta
pazienza che richiedono No Che c'è Non
ho ricominciato di nuovo delle carote
perché mi sono sfracellato non avendo
salvato vedi che ci sono anche Liverpool
è troppo difficile Sì è per Pro players
cioè quelli bravi noi siamo scarpe
Finalmente ce l'ho fatta questa
giocatrice che mi sta aspettando ve l'ho
detto ah
Ah è vero ci sono anche qua i verbi Eh
ma perché devono esserci i vermi in
questo modo che schifo il gioco Mi ha
riportato indietro le carotine qui non
riesco andare avanti
di prendere la scorciatoia e invece ti
sei sfracellato e hai perso basta con
questi laser Li odio Non ci credo ho
capito come fare per saltare le carote
praticamente ce n'era una a fianco
sempre da quel pensavo che quella lì a
fianco non lo dovessi prendere
dall'inizio che devi saltare
praticamente cioè stavo lì saltavo e
quindi cadevo sempre perché devo sempre
Ok ragazzi ce l'hai fatta Ci siamo quasi
c'è quella giocatrice lì che ha messo i
puntini puntini perché non ce la fa più
ad aspettarmi perché cazzo ah ah Mi sa
che le dico Ti conviene andare senza di
me sono troppo schiappa Voglio vedere tu
se riesci a superare questa parte senza
problemi aspetta sono appena caduto
troppo difficile basta
mi sono stato a casa No è proprio lì che
sbaglio non devi saltare a caso no non
stavo saltando a casa finora non ci
riuscivo ce l'ho fatta spiegami come hai
fatto te lo dico non ci credi Vitale ha
dovuto fare questo stage per me perché
io non riesco proprio a superare i laser
questa giocatrice sarà tipo Wow papà
perché ha detto grande
Sono ferma altri laser basta Io me ne
vado io ci credo È più facile però
prendi bene le misure Eh sì questo è più
facile è vero dobbiamo scegliere dove
andare qua non era il rosso allora
proviamo il trucchetto che mi avete
insegnato dovrebbe essere il verde Sì e
poi qua e il rosso e poi sarà il blu e
il blu Io dico che di nuovo il verde
Aspetta aspetta avete insegnato questo
trucchetto le fragole
gigantesche
Dove è finita la mia amica non la vedo
più eh Ha detto vai ho detto basta mi
sono stancata di aspettare che belle
queste fragole le fragole gigantesche
vita le torna in testa sulle uova fritte
C'è mancato poco strano che non ci siamo
sfracellati ancora parte
di torta non capisco se devo saltare nel
laser oppure no Secondo me no Beh allora
forse sì sì si può saltare nell'acqua
solo
tipo si può saltare laser e pomodoro
se non c'è il mio punto debole allora
posso andare avanti questa è una di
quelle caramelle zucchero Rose
frittatine Aspetta ho salvato che non mi
ricordo sono tornati i batteri qua oh
che cosa sono Ah bello Si può camminare
tranquillamente qua alla fine dai questa
parte è facilissimo ma bisogna saltare
sui batteri o a fianco No solo in quelli
blu quelli rossi no Uh Ci siamo quasi
stiamo per passare un'altra nel corpo
Perché questo era tipo lo stomaco tutto
quello che ha mangiato come fanno a
prendermi questi batteri ma bisogna
saltare tipo no quelli li devi evitare
quelli rossi Invece quelli blu devi
saltare sopra ma mi colpiscono sempre
saremo adesso vanno a colpirmi Che cos'è
questo ehm che parte del corpo è questa
l'intestino forse non lo so Non capisco
Ah wow aiuto è un po' strano che ci
siano queste cose in questo corpo va
bene fa niente
Uh dei tappeti elastici non l'ho aperto
Oh oh oh era arrivato qui ero arrivato
proprio qui Ah però poi sfracellati deve
ricominciare da capo mi aveva fatto
Salvare No tutte le altre che ho saltato
e quindi è tutto super troppo super
coloratissimo Sì infatti un po' strano
Ehi ma insomma Prima sono riuscita a
passare dovrò andare quello rosa sì
quanto manca ad Anita dove sei
ferma che ti dicevo io avevo paura di
quel verme Eh ma non so se è un verme
Ecco aspetta aspetta aiutami Come hai
fatto qua con questi colori Celeste Rosa
Celeste Rosa Ok grazie Ah devo evitare
No Aspetta aspetta
Vedi che io son tre Eh perché non ci
sono riuscita io prima Okay andare super
velocissimi hai capito non ti devi
fermare veloce veloce non ti fermare non
ti fermare correre saltare Eh
ce l'ho fatta l'ho salvato corri salta
corri salta salta
Questa è una delle Escape Room più
difficile che ho mai fatto sì ce l'ho
fatta Brava No no devi saltare sui rossi
gialli questa Escape Room è proprio un
Parkour difficile ed ha un sacco di
livelli Allora che cosa sono questi si è
mangiato tipo lo sturalavandini
non si sa che cosa non toccare No non
toccare il blu Eh lo so Non toccare il
laser tu sei velocissimo comunque
impossibile Sì così veloce in queste
Escape Room perché bisogna bisogna
prenderli di corsa altrimenti poi dopo
non riesci più
dove siamo stiamo risalendo nel corpo
sfracellato
In che parte del corpo saremo Allora
questa parte blu
con i muretti Rossi non l'ho mai vista
nel nostro corpo però potrei sbagliarvi
che cosa dovrebbe essere questo il DNA
tipo Wow Ma come hai fatto a passare
questo pezzo che io sono rimasto qui
bloccato devi saltare in continuazione
semplicemente ma mi prende sempre Eh Wow
siamo in Altissimo Chissà dove finiremo
oggi è uscito Mannaggia mancava poco dai
puoi farcela io continuo a salire qua
sopra Mmm Che strano Ah devo saltare
vivo forse Stiamo per uscire dal corpo
lo sai
Mmm da optare continua a srotellarsi
ce l'ho fatta Esplorando il corpo umano
Ve lo ricordate quel cartone attenzione
e arrampicati Ok ok forse forse ci sono
chissà dove siamo adesso
queste parti scompaiono vedete bisogna
andare velocissimo
battendo Sì sono in testa Ora ho capito
in che parte siamo ed è una parte che ti
aspetta perché la tua parte preferita
quindi Eh ti aspetta non posso tornare
indietro No no Quindi eravamo
nell'intestino perché qua insomma sta
uscendo qualcosa uh la puzza eh Ce l'ho
fatta Guarda cosa ti aspetta Qua sotto
abbiamo fatto una montagna tipo l'unica
strada è Saltare su queste cacchette Eh
sicuro secondo me ci sono no Vedi Hai
visto Hai bisogno surgelato Perché hai
toccato quella cosa che c'era sotto che
non voglio sapere che cos'è
e ora ora
che cosa è successo la vita Guarda cosa
c'è qua sotto buttati
impossibile Ti ho visto proprio volare
Io salto così cerco di evitare tutte le
cacchette ma sto ritornando indietro eh
eh Stai tornando indietro No questo è il
gabinetto Ecco perché stiamo finendo giù
dal gabinetto aiuto Non lo so dove sono
state andando lentissima Eh sto
arrivando piano piano
passeggiando Io pure ma sto andando
verso il badge quindi stiamo uscendo dal
corpo umano Mamma mia quanta roba c'è in
questo caso
Aspetta aspetta ci sono ci sono ci sono
dice Congratulation io vi aspetto io Va
bene Sì l'ho preso io invece
ancora qua il gabinetto intasato
guardate da Che schifo le patatine
fritte Ho preso le patatine Oh c'è da
mangiare qui c'è da mangiare attenzione
Ehm sì è proprio invitante mangiare
quando sei appena uscito da lì riesci
fuori vedi dopo si esce fuori Non ti
preoccupare eh perché fa così lento
Basta fammi scappare da questo cabinato
gigante non voglio più fare quasi ma
queste cacchette gigante
ok ti sto raggiungendo Finalmente sto
uscendo dal gabinetto
devi muoverti un po' salta salta salta
salta salta
io non vedo nessun mezzo però no non ce
n'è Belgio devi andare ancora avanti
[Musica]
questa parte gialla Vabbè se siamo nel
gabinetto ho capito che cos'è Però
allora perché mi deve far passare qua
sopra Uffa Quindi tu hai già preso il
pezzo Oh guarda guarda
guarda guarda guarda guarda Guardami
Sono qui dietro di te allora ho preso
questo che non lo so non lo dico un po'
pizzo unicorno poi ho preso il coso di
SpongeBob poi ho preso il ghiacciolo di
nov voi prendete La Palette colori che
non so che cosa serve la pizza
finalmente la pizza Ecco la pizza la
vedi la pizza
perdere fritte vai vai vai
no no no no non l'ho trovato io ma hai
detto che l'avevi preso nel senso che mi
diceva Bravo Congratulazioni hai vinto
la la scritta Boom
Oh Qua ci sono degli snack Vediamo che
cosa succede Se clicco Che carino questa
mia questa macchinetta carina credo che
si sono incastrati qua
Wow super carina eh io sono diventato
Viola Ehi ciao dove sei Sono qui dentro
di te eh
ho colorato un pochettino ah anch'io
sono diventata rossa eh Eh non lo so
perché fa così Vai vai comunque
completato le Escape Room
lasciate un bel mi piace E ora vi
lasciamo Qua quattro ragazzi su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
Clicca su quello che preferite eh Buona
visione Ciao ciao